after months of rumors that their
relationship is on the rocks kim
kardashian and kanye west may be
officially heading for divorce
a source close to the pair told forbes
that no decision is final
but confirmed that kim and kanye have
been living separately for months
this will be one of hollywood's biggest
divorces of all time
with the combined assets of the two
worth 2.1 billion dollars
though the kardashians are known for
their drama dividing the world may
actually be pretty easy
the biggest assets are independently
owned and our
kanye's yeezy empire and kim
kardashian's beauty empire
each of those assets is an independently
owned and operated business and the pair
of separate income streams and they have
since their 2014 nuptials
here's a look at what each member of the
kardashian west union might walk away
with
forbes estimates that kanye west the
richer of the two
has 1.26 billion dollars of independent
assets
that entire thing is tied up in his
yeezy brand west owns 100
of the brand which brought in around 1.3
billion dollars
in revenue in 2019. forbes estimates
that kim kardashian west is
only worth 750 million dollars but that
fortune is much more liquid
she has around 250 million dollars in
cash investments and other assets and
another 500 million dollars tied up in
your kkw beauty company
so what does that leave together the
couple owns around 70 million dollars of
combined
assets that includes their two ranches
in wyoming
their mansion in calabasas and a condo
in miami
they also have five million dollars
worth of art four million dollars in
vehicles
over three million dollars worth of
jewelry and collectibles and they even
have three hundred thousand dollars
worth of livestock
who gets one of those shared assets will
be dependent on the terms of their
prenup if they indeed had one
and whatever sentiment their lawyers can
negotiate either way both will be
walking away with plenty of money as the
70 million dollars of combined assets is
worth less than
5 of their 2.1 billion fortune
[Music]